elise est un nouveau secrétaire général
de la présidence
un condamné à mort exécuté ce matin
l'intimé conviction du président
plusieurs tremblements de terre très
violent près de pékin finale du 110 m
haies ce soir la gloire ou l'amertume
pour guy drut
bonsoir on sent bien c'est ce soir ou
jamais pour la france où nous rendrons
de montréal bredouille
ou bien vous bien car ce soir on peut
gagner deux médailles d'or dru bien sûr
mais koch aussi émis certains lèvent
l'oreille je parle judo et jean paul
koch a des chances sérieuses il s'est
classé deuxième au championnat du monde
et son vainqueur n'est pas à montréal
mais méfiance un japonais a remplacé le
japonais alors guide rue
eh bien il nous l'a dit hier soir
finalement sauté dès ce n'est qu'un jeu
mais être guy drut où tu as l'air à
montréal ça ne va pas être facile
dès la fin du journal on en sera déjà
plus nous pourrons suivre sur antenne de
sa demi-finale qu'elle dit rue véron
nous ce soir
le guide rue des championnats des états
unis un gène l'an dernier qui était
tombé comme il était en belle think i en
71 un peu plus tard aux championnats
d'europe indoor alors qu'ils étaient
super favori c'est trois courses ou
celui qui avait battu l'an passé à
berlin le record du monde du 110 m haies
s'installant du même coup grand favori
de montréal le poids des responsabilités
qu'on lui donne ne sera-t-il pas trop
lourd à porter la cellera t-il pas comme
mon cd avant lui michel jazy alain got
vallès en fait ce soir guy bru doit
envier les athlètes américains qui ne
semble pas peser sur leurs épaules
toutes les espérances dater
quand montgomery rentrera chez lui ce
sera très certainement dans l'anonymat
et pourtant il a battu le record du
monde du 100 m nage libre en moins de 50
secondes ce qui est prodigieux si gris
du guide rouge est champion olympique
imaginez ce qui se passera la descente
des champs-elysée peut-être pourquoi pas
ne pose-t-il pas aussi et malgré lui
retombé de tous ordres contre et non une
médaille d'or id rue sera tout seul ce
soir face à lui-même il devra se
débarrasser du poids écrasant de 50
millions de personnes aient retrouvé
l'état d'esprit qu'il avait à berlin
face à foster la hausse des prix
pourrait atteindre 12% pour le deuxième
semestre mais peu semestre 1976 ce sont
les prévisions de l' ocde l'organisation
de coopération et de développement
économiques
elles sont plus pessimistes que celles
de monsieur fourcade qui lui met la
barre au dessous de 10% pessimisme de l'
ocde quant à la balance commerciale
également son déficits s'accentueraient
enfin la croissance serait beaucoup
moins forte qu'au début de l'année la
situation économique a été évoqué au
conseil des ministres ce matin monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing souhaite un
budget 1977 en équilibre mais sans impôt
nouveau
on peut donc en conclure que cette année
l'état devra rogner un peu partout le
gouvernement a également pris la
décision d'envoyer une mission médicale
au liban et étudie la possibilité
d'installer de façon permanente à
beyrouth
une équipe médicale française enfin le
secrétaire général de l'elysée
n'assistait pas à ce conseil et pourtant
depuis 1974
pierre claude brosselette n'en a pas
raté sa fonction l'exigent mais ce matin
on apprenait qu'il avait été remplacé
par jean françois poncet qui était
jusque là secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre des affaires étrangères jean
françois poncet 48 ans ancien énarque
est à la fois diplomate gestionnaire
habile d'une entreprise privée est élu
local actif tout le contraire d'un
technocrate
il remplace donc claude pierre
brossolette 48 ans collaborateur depuis
quinze ans de valéry giscard d'estaing
en 74 la nomination de monsieur
brossolette à l'elysée avait paru tout
naturel
le secrétaire général n'est-il pas
l'homme de confiance du président le
plus proche collaborateur qui prépare
les dossiers donne son analyse et
participe pratiquement à toutes les
grandes décisions présidentielles
depuis quelques semaines on entendait
dire dans les couloirs de l'elysée que
les rapports entre le président et son
secrétaire général s'était altérée qu'il
y avait parfois des heures et des
visions divergentes sur la façon de
faire les choses
bref les observateurs les plus attentifs
ne sont pas surpris que monsieur giscard
d'estaing et brossolette et décidé de
suspendre leur collaboration directe
monsieur brossolette devrait retrouver
un poste important on parle de la
présidence du crédit lyonnais
ce qui prouve que l'amitié et la
confiance sont loin d'être rompu entre
les deux hommes au conseil des ministres
aucun commentaire mais plus d'un
ministre a dû se demander si ce
remaniement à l'elysée ne préludait pas
un remaniement du gouvernement qui quoi
qu'on en dise est attendu par tout le
monde
la justice des hommes est passé monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing n'a pas accordé
sa grâce
christian ranucci a été exécuté condamné
à mort pour le meurtre d'une petite
fille de 8 ans 10 mars dernier par la
cour d'assises des bouches du rhône
christian ranucci 21 ans a été décapitée
à l'aube à la prison des baumettes à
marseille
c'était ce matin à 4h30 à la sortie de
la prison des baumettes à marseille
un homme venait de mourir la tête
tranchée en 1974 il avait tué une
fillette de 8 ans la société venait
d'appliquer la loi du talion et le
président de la république en n'exerçant
pas son droit de grâce
laisser la justice suivre son cours je
pense avec la commission que la peine de
mort doit être maintenu elle doit être
appliquée dans des cas très rares pour
des crimes odieux
je pense en particulier aux rapts
d'enfants avec mort des enfants
hier cinq hommes sains condamne à mort
attendaient la grâce présidentielle
ce matin l'un d'eux a été exécuté
christian ranucci 22 ans précisément
meurtrier d'une enfant il en reste
quatre jérôme karen père de cinq enfants
il a étouffé dans la vase d'un marais
après avoir tenté de la violer une
fillette de 10 ans condamné à mort il a
encore un espoir le recours en cassation
moussa ben arfa lui aussi l'a enlevé une
enfant poursuivi est pris de panique il
l'a tuée condamné à mort pour lui plus
de recours que la grâce présidentielle
marcellin ornaise meurtrier d'un couple
d'auto stoppeurs anglais condamné à mort
s'est pourvu en cassation
joseph keller avait corniche meurtrier
des deux anglais lui aussi en cassation
ainsi dans les mois qui suivent giscard
d'estaing va se trouver à nouveau devant
le terrible dilemme gracié ou punir
alors d'où vient cette responsabilité le
droit de grâce dieu
d'après les croyances populaires le seul
personnage qui est donné la vie ces huit
égal c'est lui également qui donne la
mort et par la suite les les bras et
c'est lé roi de droit divin qui était
par conséquent les substituts de dieu
sur la terre
ce sont eux aussi donné le droit de vie
ou de mort et par extension même dans
une république laïque on en conserve
pour moi un certain nombre de solides
il ya beaucoup de rapports entre le
pouvoir et la religion c'est ainsi que
les chefs d'état d'aujourd'hui ont le
droit de vie ou de mort ni condamnation
ni grâce innocente
absolument pas je crois que c'est un
moyen pour le pouvoir de se reproduire
et ceci en s'appuyant sur un certain
désir qu'ont les foules d'être exorciser
c'est un peu comme pilate
les foules se lave les mains qu'importe
c'est le chef qui décide
le recours en grâce est prévue par la
constitution c'est l'article 17
il est obligatoire en cas de
condamnation à mort la procédure est
longue il ya de nombreux rapports des
réunions avec le chef de l'état et le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
jusqu'au jour où le président de la
république est seul seul devant deux
documents un ordonne la commutation de
peine en réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
c'est la grâce l'autre laisse la justice
suivre son cours
c'est l'ordre d'exécution et le
président de la république par une
simple signature condamne ou sow alors
cette question
les jurés qui décide du verdict ne se
sentent pas déchargé de la
responsabilité par le fait du recours
je trouve que c'est un droit qui permet
beaucoup de lâcheté aux jurés et se
disent condamnant à mort elle souverain
s'il veut grâce rats il n'y aurait pas
de grâce paix qui n'hésiteraient
davantage aux vrais partisans qui sont
responsables de leurs décisions et
qu'ils y assistent à l'exécution
c'est donc le président de la république
et lui seul qui porte la responsabilité
de l'exécution lourde responsabilité à
laquelle chaque candidat à l'elysée a
pensé avant son élection
giscard d'estaing avait fait connaître
son aversion profonde envers la peine de
mort mais aujourd'hui président de la
république il y à la raison d'état
pour ce qui est de la peine de mort je
souhaite que la communauté nationale
française et donc son législateur se
saisissent le moment venu de ce problème
naturellement il convient sans doute pas
de le faire à un moment où la situation
de violence en particulier de certaines
violences inadmissibles
randa société française
extraordinairement sensibilisés à ce
problème
et parmi les violences inadmissibles que
je citerai il ya deux cas qui sont les
cas de rapt prémédité d'enfants
comportant pour eux la quasi certitude
de la mort ceci par un calcul d'intérêt
et s'est d'autre part le cas de ceux qui
avec un acharnement inhumain s'attaque à
des personnes âgées isolées en ayant
préparé leur agression pour leur
soustraire leurs malheureuses ressources
je crois que nous devons faire en sorte
que la vague de criminalité et de
violence s'atténue en france et ceci
suppose un certain nombre de moyens de
prévention et d'action et que cette
vague ayant reculé
il deviendra possible que cela
nécessaire que la collectivité nationale
se pose la question de la peine de mort
sur laquelle en ce qui me concerne le
moment venu je donnerai ma réponse
voilà dans le contexte de la violence
actuelle c'est-à-dire avec le poids de
l'opinion publique avec le rôle de la
presse dans ce climat d'insécurité
l'opinion souhaite et à une large
majorité que la peine capitale reste
dans notre droit et continuent d'être
appliqués 1969 33% pour la peine de mort
1975 56% poids d'une opinion publique
réagit au jour le jour en fonction des
événements et n'a pas toujours flirté
nécesaire aujourd'hui une autre
constitution est tel que celui qui
exerce le droit de grâce n'est pas dans
les meilleures conditions pour le faire
il ne s'agit pas de faire procès
d'intention un chef d'état qui quels
qu'ils soient j'en suis sûr
prend sa décision dans son armée dans sa
conscience
mais cette âme et cette conscience à
partir du moment où ce chef d'état est
devenu
chef de majorité politique est encore
une fois de majorité politique quel
qu'il soit et bien cette âme et cette
conscience dépendent de l'image que lui
renvoie l'opinion et ça ça me paraît
très mauvais enfin dernière question si
demain vous aviez à défendre on
quelqu'un de condamné à mort vous allez
trouver un président l'a dit qu'elles
font que diriez vous prenez et bien
justement je serai en général de lui
rappeler que avant d'assumer la charge
qui est la sienne il a le plus souvent
été un adversaire convaincu de la peine
de mort et j'essayerai de lui montrer
que cette responsabilité politique
nouvelle qui l'exercent ne l'autorisent
pas à renier ses opinions d'autrefois
qui est lé bol dans ce débat sur la
peine de mort les arguments des uns
n'ont jamais convaincu les autres la
peine de mort et l exemplaire et
dissuasive comme le prétend certains ce
n'est pas sur le châtiment ne décourage
pas forcément les criminels mais il y à
tous ces détournements ces attentats une
opinion qui veut être sécurisé et c'est
là où la politique prend le pas sur le
coeur
soyons francs un président n'est jamais
seul lorsqu'il signe la grâce d'un
condamné ou lorsqu'il laisse au
contraire la justice suivre son cours
du côté du pur comme du côté du contre
ils sont une foule innombrable de gens
qui vont l'applaudir ou plus
discrètement la prouver la véritable
solitude le véritable choix d'une
dernière justice n'existerait que si la
décision et ses conséquences restée
secrète c'est impossible
comme il est impossible de ne pas penser
que la réflexion politique le poids de
l'opinion et rumeurs de la foule
n'influe pas la décision de l'homme
public des influences qui pèse
d'ailleurs déjà dans un premier temps
sur les juges et jurés la cour d'assises
d'autant que le président de la
république doit lui se prononcer
concrètement définitivement sur un
problème
un drame chaque fois différent alors que
la foule des citoyens se décide dans
l'abstrait pour ou contre la mort
résultat d'une réflexion intellectuelle
d'une option philosophique politique et
la plupart du temps conséquence d'une
réaction viscérale ceux qui sont pour la
mort sont aussi souvent ceux qui
hésitent à la choisir dans le secret
délibérée des cours d'assises
ceux qui sont contre le couperet que je
n'ai jamais caché que j'en faisais
partie
la réclame parfois comme un dû lorsque
leur enfant leur femme ou leur mère sont
éventrés ou assailli la peine de mort la
sagesse voudrait qu'on y réfléchisse
qu'on en parle à la rigueur quand on
décide or des mouvements de passion en
fait on ne sous paient cette raison
qu'au travers le visage d'une victime ou
celui de son meurtrier
les règles sont fausses et valéry
giscard d'estaing voudrait que les temps
se calme et que les français prennent en
conscience leurs responsabilités il l'a
dit en souriant peut-être que le dernier
débat à l'assemblée sur la peine de mort
remonte à 1908
cette affaire de sang se transmet de
génération en génération
en attendant qu'un président risque des
voix ou sa tranquillité ou d'autres
urgences pour demander aux français à
chacun de nous s'il est capable ou
signés tant de dissocier la vengeance de
l'idée de justice
rupture entre la grande bretagne et
l'ouganda rupture des relations
diplomatiques annoncé devant la chambre
des communes dans le secrétaire au
foreign office c'est la première fois
que la grande bretagne prend une telle
décision à l'encontre d'un pays du
commonwealth
notre ambassade ne pouvais plus remplir
son rôle efficacement ont déclaré les
anglais députés travaillistes et
conservateurs ont applaudi cette
décision mais avec réserve car il reste
quelques 200 sujets britanniques en
ouganda
c'est la france qui représentera les
intérêts de la grande bretagne auprès du
gouvernement du général à minden les
communistes espagnols abandonne la
clandestinité
réunis à rome le comité central du parti
communiste d'espagne a décidé ce matin
d'agir au grand jour malgré l'illégalité
la présidente du parti madame ibarruri
de pasionaria a rappelé que les
communistes espagnols n'entendent pas
obéir à une discipline internationale
quant au secrétaire général du parti
monsieur carillo il n'a pas exclu la
possibilité d'engager le dialogue avec
le gouvernement
pas de réaction à madrid où on a appris
cet après-midi le prochain voyage
officiel de juan carlos en france au
mois d'octobre
quinze mille personnes menacées
d'évacuation à seveso près de milan le
nuage toxique échappé de l'usiné
chimique fait peser de graves dangers à
la population les experts italiens sont
toujours à essayer de comprendre ce qui
s'est passé à essayer de limiter la zone
réellement contamine les dirigeants de
lusine rythme et sa responsable de
l'échappement de ghazi aux-in sont en
prison la firme suisse mise en cause a
promis de verser 100 millions de lires à
peu près 500 mille francs français pour
dédommager les victimes italiennes
la sonde viking a commencé à creuser le
sol de mars l'ordre lui en a été donnée
par les spécialistes américains de
passer dena en californie les
techniciens ne savent pas encore si le
bras articulé
l'excavateur fonctionne bien il faudra
attendre les prochaines photos
mais ce net au mieux que dans une
semaine que les analyses des
échantillons prélevés permettront de
dire si oui ou non il ya autour de
victimes des traces de vie la réponse à
cette interrogation pourrait être donnée
à la fin du mois d'août seulement
terrible séisme en chine depuis dix ans
jamais un tremblement de terre n'avait
atteint une telle violence les appareils
qui ont enregistré la secousse au
commissariat à l'énergie atomique à
paris ont été saturés et n'ont pu le
mesurer sont l'épicentre se trouve à 150
km de pékin dans la région de tianjin
une province très peuplée et d'après les
premiers témoins il y aurait des morts
et les dégâts seraient très importants
la première secousse la nuit dernière a
été ressentie jusqu'à pékin où des
maisons se sont fissurées et des murs se
sont écroulés
pourtant pourtant la chine est à la
pointe de la recherche en ce qui
concerne les prédictions des
tremblements de terre
paysans et scientifiques y participent
et observe les uns avec de savants
instruments ou les algues et c'est
souvent très simples et les autres avec
des instruments très sophistiqué mais il
semble que cette fois ci la méthode a
été prise en défaut depuis une quinzaine
d'années la terre gronde un peu partout
dans le monde et les spécialistes du
monde entier se penche sur les grandes
cassure connu et même en amérique les
savants s'inquiète de ces catastrophes à
répétition
après le guatemala l'italie la chine san
francisco la californie est ce que la
terre est en colère
les sismologues américains ne le pense
pas et en général ils savent ce qu'ils
disent car il dispose ici en californie
des installations les plus modernes de
recherche et de prédiction l'homme qui
fait référence à la matière charles
richter ne s'émeut pas s'inquiète
mènerait je pense que c'est
essentiellement une question de chance
explique le professeur richter
l'activité sismique ne change guère
d'année en année mais évidemment elle
apparaît beaucoup plus importante dès
qu'un tremblement de terre touche une
région très peuplée
on lire alors quand un tremblement de
terre touche une région peuplée tout le
monde s'excite mais par conséquent il
n'y a pas spécialement ce moment de
menaces de tremblement de terre non je
pense que nous sommes dans une bonne
moyenne
une bonne moyenne qui ne rassure pas
pour autant ceux qui vivent dans une
zone dangereuse
hollis terre près de san francisco est
l'un de ces carrefours les plus menacés
deux failles traverse cette petite ville
de 8000 habitants
hollister est bourrée d'instruments de
mesure comme les 1000km de la faille qui
coupe la californie on enregistre la
moindre secousse mais souvent trop tard
pour qu'une prédiction soit vraiment
valable il faut que l'on puisse dire
quand va se produire le tremblement de
terre
aujourd'hui nous savons où il se produit
et comment mais la question est quand la
plupart des savants estime que la
prédiction est possible nous avons
beaucoup de signes qui permettent
d'annoncer un tremblement de terre ici
comme en chine au japon
ce sont des signes qui peuvent être
mesurer très précisément c'est pourquoi
il me paraît possible d'arriver un jour
à prédire un tremblement de terre mais
cela nécessite beaucoup d'expérience
beaucoup d'observation en attendant des
habitants de san francisco préfère
rester dans leur ville menacée exposées
tout en beauce et en crevasse
mais où il fait si bon vivre c'est donc
tout de suite après ce journal que nous
suivrons sans doute avec ferveur dans
les demi finales puis plus tard les 13
secondes de course de guide et que nous
saurons si oui ou non nous émettons une
médaille d'or on était raisonnable
pourtant savait qu'on peut en avoir
beaucoup
mais aujourd'hui on se demande encore
pourquoi alors que nous en avait promis
plusieurs en voile les épreuves pour la
france ont toutes été décevante
l'entraîneur de la voile française
monsieur max gombert n'y est pas allé
par quatre chemins si nous étions des
âmes bonheur tel un amiral nous courions
notre flotte
ce commentaire musclée de capitaine en
perdition suffirait presque à expliquer
la déroute française
aucune médaille alors que les français
étaient attendus et espérés au moins
dans deux disciplines le fim et le 4,70
c'est à dire serge maury champion
olympique à munich
d'une part et marc laurent et roger
surmelin d'autre part eu champion du
monde échec total
et voici le bilan chiffré les deux
derniers sont huitième mort y ait 10
yens quant aux autres résultats en
flying dutchman par exemple et faire
pajot son huitième hausse aux lignes et
glee levrat est troublé son septième
après avoir fait assez longtemps figure
de favori les déceptions partout donc et
dans quelques jours
après la tempête de kingston il faudra
répondre à cette question à kingston at
on assisté à une défaillance humaine ou
technique
aujourd'hui il a fait à s'ébouler
température était agréable elle variait
de 18 degrés au havre à 31 à perpignan
demain le soleil brillera les
températures seront sensiblement les
mêmes que celles d'aujourd'hui de la
normandie et de la bretagne aux alpes et
aux pyrénées
quelques nuages du nord à l'alsace et au
jura avec la rédaction d'antenne 2 je
vous souhaite de passer une très bonne
soirée à demain je vous rappelle que
dans trois minutes environ nous serons
en direct avec montréal tout juste après
les spots publicitaires et avant de
refermer journal voici les titres qu'il
faut retenir de l'actualité aujourd'hui
elysées jean-françois conseil nouveau
secrétaire général de la présidence
christian ranucci décapité ce matin à
marseille il avait tué une enfant de
huit ans une française parmi les
victimes des tremblements de terre en
chine
dans quelques heures une médaille d'or
possibles pour guy drut
vers minuit le dernier journal présenté
par philippe harrouard
oh